Donald Trump flew all the way to the
French countryside to a world war one
cemetery in honor of the troops who
fought in that war although he didn't
quite make it
he made it to a hotel in Paris and
ultimately called off his participation
in the event because it was raining and
instead he watched television Winston
Churchill's grandson Nicholas Soames
who's a member of the British Parliament
blasted Trump as pathetic and inadequate
for failing to show up this is
disrespectful to the troops to their
families Trump said he'd be the best on
the military that's not happening this
is disrespectful to every American
taxpayer who bears the cost of this trip
for Trump to sit around watching
television and tweeting here are German
and French leaders Angela Merkel and
Emmanuel macron both apparently able to
brave the brutal reign and stand there
for a few minutes between limo rides
rain not something that would stop Trump
from golfing however here's a picture of
Donald Trump
playing golf in the rain that certainly
didn't seem to deter him there but
honoring the troops after traveling all
the way to Europe in the rain apparently
just too much to ask
is there any bigger snowflake than this
guy 93 year old Queen Elizabeth the
second had no problem whatsoever making
it out to all of the events of the day
and it's really not at all surprising
when you think back to Trump being the
guy who got a deferment out of Vietnam
because his foot hurt
later he couldn't remember which foot it
was maybe it was both of them who even
knows who even really cares right and if
you want a manly president this is not
something I care about okay but there
are many Trump supporters who are all
about Obama was bata and Trump is alpha
by your own standards you've got to be
missing Obama at this point right here
is President
Obama greeting supporters in the rain
here he is giving a speech with no
umbrella in the rain here's President
Obama honoring fallen soldiers in the
rain with no umbrella mind you and I
could go on and imagine for a second
what would right-wingers have done if
President Obama had done this can you
even imagine because it would have been
a far bigger scandal than the time Obama
chose the wrong mustard for the cuisine
he was eating it would be worse than the
time Obama wore a tan suit on a day when
he was scheduled to deal with serious
issues Trump bragged remember that he
would have run into the high school in
parkland Florida Margaery Stoneham
Douglass High School during that mass
shooting if only he had been there and
he can't even honor the troops in the
rain and were supposed to believe he
would have run into a building with an
active shooter to defend high schoolers
can anybody answer me this question Pat
what's more disrespectful kneeling
during the national anthem before a
football game or refusing to go out in
the rain after flying to Europe on a
trip meant to honor the troops because
it's sprinkling and you might get wet
well you know me I would certainly say
the latter but I do have the explainer
for this and it's Trump's hair he can't
afford to get that thing wet he could
say that the man could use an umbrella
but we have video evidence showing that
he actually doesn't know how to close
the umbrella so there's no way he could
have possibly made this event I mean
just the hairstyle alone that meerkat
for a hairstyle not gonna allow them to
do it we're going to get to the
geopolitical implications of this but
this guy is pathetic he mocked John
McCain for being captured in the
military he says that he made sacrifices
just like gold star families have done
and the guy doesn't go out in the rain
he respects dictators and himself period
that is it and I'm getting lots of
emails from people saying David is it
even really necessary for the president
to go
Europe to commemorate a hundred years of
the end of World War one like it's not
even clear that his presence was
necessary you can have that debate I
agree that Trump's presence wasn't
necessary but this event is actually a
pretty big deal in the UK and in Europe
and the important thing here is that if
you decide to go and then you actually
make it there go to the event don't sit
in your hotel room watching TV because
it's raining while a 93 year old Queen
is able to make it out there this is the
most beta of beta totally triggered
snowflake and it's an absolute
embarrassment to this country and we're
gonna be talking about that extensively
later today I've got a piece I'm
planning for you tomorrow about how
world leaders are just sick of Trump's
BS and they're making it clear that
they're sick of Trump's BS this is sort
of it's it's a story that is about a
micro issue that's going on but it
actually is emblematic of so much of
what's wrong with this guy and we're
gonna be talking about it
today's program is sponsored in part by
the mr and ms collection offering our
audience 20% off when you use the coupon
code Pakman at checkout I need this
I can barely figure out how to dress
it's embarrassing to say but the mr. and
Miss collection is your own personal
wardrobe styling service for both men
and women and here's how it works you
tell them about your sizes and
preferences you tell them how you like
to dress what your sort of general style
is and their team of stylists will
handpick clothing items that are styled
just for you and customized to your
needs you get the clothes you can wear
the ensemble they picked out for you you
can mix and match each item with clothes
you already own you can keep any of the
clothes as long as you want but when you
do decide to send things back they'll
send you a whole new set of clothes
selected once again just for you you
even have the option of buying an item
if it's something you really like and
it's all included with one low monthly
fee shipping is always free you get
several pieces of clothing for a price
you would usually pay for one
item at a store great way to evolve your
personal style but you can continually
give them feedback about what you like
and don't like it's especially great for
all of the holiday parties and
get-togethers that are coming up over
the next couple of months a subscription
also makes a great holiday gift for
somebody else and our viewers can get
20% off just click the link underneath
this video select men or women and use
coupon code PA k ma n at checkout